are you are you what are you Italian and
Irish half half Italian and Irish
Siciliano me too
let's see the difference is I look I
look Irish yeah and I've got the body in
the [ __ ] of an Italian I don't know you
look like like a little tiny Swedish boy
you know I like a little Swedish boy
yourself it may be little tiny Swedish
boy yeah I'm a Brian a Calum yeah you
the other Brian a Calum that's an Irish
girl and I and I know horrible Swedish
is an Irish guy this is clearly Irish
man whoa do yes that's Irish Jamaican no
this is Irish guy that's so to make
entire okay welcome to Ireland
no that's no welcome to the island of
Ireland man the very land come over get
some fish and chips and fruit and salad
not see that falafel this is Ireland
salad couscous on the island of Ireland
oh that sounds so Jamaican is not even
close to Jamaican to make an accent you
want to Jimmy hey I'm Jamaican I'm a big
black Jamaican guy everyone knows I'm
Jamaican best Jamaican super Australian
you're so bad with dialects you don't
know I don't I studied in college dude I
did dialectical research that was one of
my focuses what was your what was your
major in college journalism and English
journaling journalism major English
focus and I had a dialectic subset I did
two and a half years of learning
dialects around the world came but name
a place and I can do it Maori Maori you
want Maori yeah okay
welcome to diesel nobody
iya iya puddin or mommy me hold you on
daughter sheep and you didn't understand
the language because I was also knowing
okay okay Russian Russian Russians
probably probably one of my favorites to
be honest with Russians easy Russian
goes I don't you want to eat you want to
eat fish or you do you want to go on
your separate ways because dinner is met
okay now I have to all right that's well
now looks I don't take this the wrong
way but that does sound a little bit
French well you you're going you want me
to kick out here some more big day okay
all right can I hear these and don't
make it okay don't make it can I hear it
Joplin is easy Japanese is probably one
of my favorite wants to do I have to get
prepped for it ready yeah you're mine
right whoo I don't know you don't know
how to do this with me I wanna dance on
your lap and maybe shake em up ooh
suppose I have to stop here because it's
so good did you just get transform like
you were back in Tokyo Japan I'm so
[ __ ] Spanish you guys are so wrong I
maybe I am I'm telling you you're wrong
I went to a [ __ ] school for
dialectical research okay maybe we're
off I don't maybe Maya I go to college I
did go did you go to college or did with
college I went to American University in
DC DC yeah that's a really good school I
know it is what did you do what was your
major history economics history then it
was history yeah economics and history
well it was economics and I switched
over to history when was the war of 1812
that's a good question in the 1800's
sometimes when you see my back ripple
and I pull myself up like a champ like a
champ thirty times while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a Gish it's a gift it's a gift